is it a good idea investing it's not a
horrible idea wonderment ran the
experiment ran it was a pretty
successful experiment I mean there have
been some listen babe there have been
some pretty big hits there have been
some pretty big misses you know they got
a big hit like fiscal note stuff pretty
well the doorman fund Bevi the beverage
companies done pretty well for fun
Brooklyn yeah student founders yeah
Brooklyn in the linens company I'm sure
I'm gonna get probably railed on Twitter
after for not having come up with the
whole portfolio but I'm sure there are
more that I can't think of and on the
missus side you have like Lily AI which
is the other if you guys remember Lily
trone's yeah yeah they raised like I
know 30 the exact number they raised a
bunch then kind of flamed out and that's
the the counter side you can have people
who another dude I mean listen there's
like an important socialization element
to college which helps you learn
emotional maturity and learn how to deal
with people and it's tough if you don't
have that I don't know when you make it
up certainly don't make it up by moving
straight out here I'm working really
hard early I use all my friends my
friends after you graduate your friends
who you met in college and then the rest
are just you just go to work and then
you go home and you like wait where to
keep my friends after that there's no
more friends I'm like Rico I think of
college
yeah for sure
yeah Shah who produces the podcast he's
always like oh well you know you know
he's like 20
well you have you know experience you
have capital you have this network you
know I'm like dude I would give all of
it up just be right back where you are
in your position right now I'll trade
you if we can do something really Friday
I painted the agreement we remember that
young guy oh you were there we met a
young guy at our meet up and he was like
21 and he flew up and like wow so like
if I was if I was 18 and I've lived you
know went to NYU yeah I would be not be
in the dorm I would only do the dorm
room fun if it helped me meet girls in
Soho and you're 18 that's the dream NYU
was a really fun college to go to and
certainly had a really fun time there
but here's the flip side of it right
like I see the other side of this which
is it does feel today like they're
compounding effects both of
reputationally and professionally so
we're working and exposing yourself to
provide some kind of real tangible
ownership of work really early and the
earlier you can do that whether it's
like a startup or working for a large
company in a significant role or
building some reputation even if it's
just tweeting dumb jokes on Twitter like
that compounds over time and if you wait
five years you can do you can both have
fun and build compounding professional
returns at the same time it's sort of
the argument I would make here you can
do those yeah but it's not as fun as
just doing the fun it's not accessible
it's just doing the success but a lot of
folks try to lock that so you'll end up
way ahead of the curve yeah best of all
or just having fun and not doing
anything that way it's their lot of like
career foundation ironically when you're
in college okay so you you do all this
yeah and by the way when you said
emergence you really emphasized the C at
the end of it is it because people think
it's emergent so I I think people
there's a couple things one of people
think it's emergence capital people
think it's like emerge Capital I've
heard like five or six different issues
of the name the other thing is our
website is EMC AP comm are you going to
first join that say oh it's M cap and
people are like oh the letter M and then
the you know see AP I probably had a
rebrand not up to me my probably had
like six months of emails I didn't get
because it more like oh this jerk gave
me like a wrong email address of that
party I guess I'm saying I was screaming
M cap on the top of my lungs people are
like oh yeah like Zak M cap
MC ap right so we're up to maybe a
different URL
[Music]